I pointed out that these people that
want to censor me and by the way the
point of writing a report attacking me
as well as Bjorn lombborg and Jordan
Peterson as climate deniers and climate
delayers the whole point of that is to
de-platform me and prevent organizations
like the BBC or the New York Times from
interviewing us or having us included
it's a college assassination it's a
concerted assassination as soon as I saw
this report of course I asked to
interview the people that wrote the
report to have some sort of conversation
with them so they would correct the
record they have absolutely refused and
so what I've pointed out is there's
something quite pathological about this
you have the people that are demanding
that I be censored refuse to stand in
public conversation or even in a podcast
interview with me this is you know at
least in the Spanish Inquisition you had
a chance to respond to your interrogator
so there's something pathological about
this because this kind of behavior is
unacceptable this is how you get to
totalitarianism